like we don't give a [ __ ] about I don't
even [ __ ] about who like my [ __ ] yeah I
don't care uh I stopped giving the [ __ ]
who like my [ __ ]
ten years ago ro you know what I gave a
[ __ ] who like my [ __ ] when I gave a [ __ ]
about who like my [ __ ] when I was
signing in Jeezy I was like damn man I
wonder if people like it because he was
always about that I don't give a [ __ ] if
you like my music my [ __ ] my [ __ ] once
I got rich I stopped giving the [ __ ] let
me ask you to hand off the top of the
top and I mean that once I got broke
Lambo just called me this week
well that was I'm about three weeks ago
and he bought a brand new house bro you
know I'm saying so it's like bro all my
people and my family around me is doing
good
you know me so I don't really give a
[ __ ] about nothing else that's all I
give a [ __ ] about how big we talked
about this before we started the podcast
talk about the motivation that you've
that fueled you from disbanding from CTE
correct because I was easy
he's a motivation every day you know why
because I look up to young G I didn't
start listening man or a rope come on
bro 2010 I could have [ __ ] with any
rapper [ __ ] I could have [ __ ] with Yo
Gotti
Rick Ross anybody how I'm gonna do I
remember I looked to Otto's [ __ ] I was
there I'm saying but I really lit up
seen Young Jeezy and I was like you know
me I look up to him so that said you
know every autumn use that I mean after
that it's the you know to prove [ __ ]
wrong to fool that I was where I was
supposed to be you know I'm saying so
you know that little bit of motivation
like you know it gives me a you know
give me that push you know I'm saying so
I you know every day every time I go in
the booth every project I make I'm
trying to prove somebody you're wrong
and I'm saying I'm from Gary Indiana bro
and I'm the all the [ __ ] rapper
from there [ __ ] City
yeah and that [ __ ] is no [ __ ] once it
is that [ __ ] ain't no coincidence Ari so
it's like this because
I got a different mentality than a lot
of [ __ ] you know I'm saying I'll take
the adversity and I use this [ __ ]
fuel you know I'm saying a lot of people
don't do that comes in and the fact that
I can do that you know puts me above a
lot of [ __ ] you know I'm saying like
bro I wasn't supposed to make in 2006
Interscope drop me I remember I'm saying
all those I wasn't supposed to be where
I'm at right now and your longevity is
because childs are just blaze for all
the unapproved beats that release they
right shall do I'm just saying though
like like you know I'm not supposed to
be where I'm at right now but I'm here
because you know I mean pure
perseverance and Lambo I mean you got a
Lambo I always tell you this I'm like
dude you like there were times where it
would have been easy for you to make the
industry move and to like not piss off
whoever you pissed off or but you're you
are who you are and you never compromise
that and like even if it meant you you
know burn it like who gives like yo I'm
Fred so what like take me as I am or go
[ __ ] yourself come on man cheers Cheers
Young Jeezy is musically irrelevant just
be real dawg
you know man be real did you this says
that sobbing oh you [ __ ] did it
I mean I love I'd like to comment on it
well we don't know question I don't
wanna be legend listen a legend I will
say this but right now you're you ask me
a question and what you want to do you
want to fight you don't want that listen
I love you I understand that you feel
you but you know you can't let me speak
I fight me you can't I'll rat me
I think it I can't beat me up I'll rat
me I don't really give a [ __ ] up red let
me get some what a fourth red listen
Fred I'm here to speak and Lambo look
you you refugees are you gonna invite me
to her cuz then they could be ducking me
do you remember when you and when you
were in Vegas and it was me you and
Jeezy on the same interview I think it's
the only time you guys did an interview
together on YouTube we was yeah station
no you guys were together what it's
remember when you guys had the show at
the pearl
and then me now me you and your girl we
went across the street made a [ __ ]
[ __ ] teach you I don't remember we
did Cheers
but with that being said GZ you are a
legend that being said not a fan of your
last album if anything I gave it I gave
it a real go last hour my enjoy to Jesus
was TM 103 roll your last three she's
been not that